[Musique]
à notre panel ce soir Émilie Nicola
Hélène buzetti et Jonathan Trudeau
bonsoir à vous trois bonsoir on va
commencer par cette annonce d'élection
partielle sans Henri Sainte-Anne on a la
date maintenant 13 mars pour remplacer
évidemment Dominique Anglade dans une
circonscription qui jusqu'à maintenant
toujours été remporté par les libéraux
la question c'est est-ce que ça va
continuer avec le candidat que les
libéraux présente aujourd'hui
Christopher beninger très peu connu en
fait peut-être assez courageux malgré
tout c'était présenté dans le circuit
circonscription à côté contre Manon Macé
dans cette Paris Saint-Jacques il avait
obtenu 16% des voix donc il était arrivé
deuxième et Jonathan je commence avec
vous est-ce que est-ce que vous êtes
capable lui de garder le château fort
libéral
mais la logique voudrait que oui ce
serait un désastre si le persil du
Québec qui était pas en mesure de
conserver ce côté-là je sens un certain
mécontentement ou une déception du côté
de bonhomme de militants libéraux qui
vraiment espéré que ce soit une
candidature très très forte qui envoie
un message clair que le Parti libéral se
remet sur les rails on a souvent cette
empressement là du côté du côté des
libéraux mais en même temps mettez-vous
à la place des organisateurs du parti
bérale à la place de Marc Tanguay ce ne
sont pas des conditions favorables pour
récolter de de grosses pointures si tu
peux me permettre de le dire ainsi c'est
un parti qui n'a pas de chef donc qui se
cherche un chef mais qui se cherche
aussi une identité et on le sent de plus
en plus depuis bon nombre d'années donc
c'était pas évident pour eux soyons bien
clair il a un CV très intéressant
monsieur Ballanger
il parle quatre langues a été élevé en
Europe un entrepreneur social qui fait
du développement durable un combat de
tous les instants mais reste au niveau
de la notoriété qu'on recherche souvent
ça de nos jours ben ça reste à bâtir
pour lui bon alors une candidature
intéressante Hélène mais dans un
contexte comme Jonathan le disait de
partir qui est pas très favorable ils
ont même pas de chef c'est encore un
chef par intérim oui exactement et puis
c'est pas très alléchant de pour
convaincre des nouveaux candidats de
dire venez chez nous vous allez être
dans les banquettes de l'opposition de
face à un gouvernement majoritaire qui
est là pour un autre 4 ans et comme vous
le dites 100 chefs et sans orientation
alors c'est sûr que c'est pas très
évident en même temps tout est à faire
tout reste à faire donc peut-être que
certains peuvent y voir là une occasion
d'imprimer une marque au parti ou un
nouveau souffle une nouvelle orientation
mais clairement ça n'a pas totalement
fonctionné dans ce cas-ci moi je suis
quand même je j'accroche sur le fait que
la candidature qui acquiste soit assez
peu connu un engin à 21 ans mais on va
le montrer justement à l'écran la
candidature kakis le Victor fel
voilà exactement il était un ancien
président de l'île jeunesse donc
clairement c'est pas un candidat sur
lequel la CAC a beaucoup fait reposer
beaucoup d'espoir mais je me demande
s'il y a pas un peu de stratégie même de
ce côté-là d'avoir un candidat assez
effacé parce que on veut voir cette
bataille à la CAQ qu'on veut voir cette
bataille entre le Parti libéral et
QS voire peut-être même qu'on aimerait
ça que US gagne parce que dans la tête
de monsieur Legault avoir comme
adversaire les méchants de la gauche
QS c'est gagnant on l'avait vu ils se
sont fait quelques ils ont quelques
prises de bec dans le passé et donc je
me demande si pour la CAQ il y a
peut-être pas un calcul de dire ben on
pourrait comme ça mettre un dernier clou
dans le cercueil libéral et choisir
notre adversaire contre lequel on croit
avoir plus de chance on voit
actuellement les trois candidats qui
sont connus parce que le pick-up a
encore annoncé son candidat on n'en sait
rien non plus du côté du conservateur
c'est Guillaume cliché Rivard qui se
présente pour une deuxième fois dans la
circonscription pour Quebec solidaire
Émilie est-ce que c'est aussi votre
lecture finalement c'est une bataille en
deux parties d'opposition
ça avait été serré à trois voix quand
même la durant durant la dernière
campagne électorale donc générale
ceci dit cette même division là des
votes peut faire en sorte que ça peut
être difficile à prédire quand même le
résultat surtout qu'on avait quand même
pour du côté des libéraux une chef il y
a toujours une prime à l'une quand une
chaîne du parti qui se présente dans une
circonscription donc on peut pas penser
que les résultats électoraux de de la
dernière élection d'octobre vont être
les mêmes que cette fois-ci donc c'est
sûr que ça donne une chance aussi à
Guillaume l'écrivain qui est quand même
fait beaucoup de terrains lors de
l'élection d'octobre et qui donc aussi
compte sur une équipe de bénévoles qui
est déjà probablement prête à reprendre
à reprendre du service on sait que du
côté des libéraux ça a été très
difficile d'avoir de la dernière
élection
général d'avoir aussi des bénévoles dans
les côtés les élections partielles c'est
beaucoup de questions de terrain parce
que c'est pas vrai qu'il y a une
attention politique nationale sur une
élection partielle donc c'est vraiment
une question de porte de faire sortir le
vote parce que les taux de participation
historiquement sont toujours très bas
dans les élections partielles donc les
parties qui ont moins de bénévoles qui
sont moins organisés sur le terrain vont
aussi
avoir un obstacle supplémentaire donc ça
peut être aussi une stratégie par
exemple pour François Legault pour
certains partis de baisser les attentes
dans la manière dont ils présentent les
choses pour ensuite travailler sur le
terrain et de causer la surprise c'est
probablement sur leur espoir mais est-ce
que c'est important pour Québec
solidaire et votre vie ministre élection
je pense que oui je pense que ça fait
c'était un des des comtés qui étaient
dans leur mir la dernière fois ils ont
eu quand même un député de plus
après l'élection d'octobre il y a eu une
déception de perdre de perdre une
députée en Abitibi donc quand même je
pense que pour Québec solidaire ça
ferait bien avoir cette victoire
électorale même si en même temps il y a
ça aussi de se décoller de l'image d'un
parti Montréal donc ça serait une
victoire peut-être pas la meilleure
victoire que Québec solidaire peut
espérer dans dans le récit qu'ils
essaient de construire demain et Marc
Tanguay le chef a intérim donc du Parti
libéral nous a donné un avant-goût
aujourd'hui du genre d'attaque qui
veulent faire à Québec solidaire dans le
cadre de cette élection partielle on va
l'écouter
nous sommes confiants que les citoyens
citoyennes de service Sainte-Anne
méritent un député à Québec un député
libéral en la personne de Christopher
bininger qui va défendre les droits et
libertés qui va être clair là-dessus et
qui n'aurait jamais lui voté
contrairement à Québec solidaire comme
la carte le fait Québec Solidaire a été
caché sur le projet de loi 96 Québec
sanitaire a été tous au solidaire
lorsqu'on votait pour la loi 96 sauf
pour le dire et on est confiant que les
gens vont dire effectivement ça tient
pas la route
Québec solidaire qui a été caché sur la
loi 96 Jonathan est-ce que c'est un
argument qui peut porter effectivement
dans cette circonscription
de voir que déjà Marc Tanguy cible
l'adversaire on se fait pas de cachette
il est à l'attaque dans ce qu'on vient
d'entendre mais il risque quand on
regarde les positions de départ il y a
un parti qui va être sur la défensive
c'est-à-dire on veut sauver les meubles
on peut pas se permettre de perdre un
autre côté imagine déjà les libéraux
c'était catastrophiques d'avoir fait et
lire seulement 21 députés à la dernière
élection ils ont perdu ma Claude Nikos
qui est rendu indépendante s'il fallait
qu'il perde de façon permanente ce comté
là ce serait catastrophique pour eux
alors qu'à l'opposé vous avez Québec
solidaire qui lui est vraiment dans un
mode plus offensif qui tente de faire
des gains je reviens sur un élément qui
milit un mentionné qui est absolument
pertinent intéressant c'est le défi pour
les libéraux de mobiliser les gens
d'anciens rue Sainte-Anne parce que la
base militante elle est là pour le PLK
mais ce sera difficile de mobiliser de
motiver les gens alors quel opposé
Québec solidaire avait fait presque du
jamais vu lors de la dernière élection
en je pense c'était quatre fois Gabriel
nado Dubois dans Paris Saint-Anne alors
que normalement on laisse le comté de du
chef d'une autre formation politique un
peu plus tranquille donc il connaissent
ce côté-là déjà ils ont sillonné de d'un
bout à l'autre donc la machine
électorale de Québec solidaire risque
d'être gonflé en bloc à bloc malgré la
période assez léthargique qu'ils ont eu
après l'élection mais là il semble être
revenu bien en scène
malgré la literie manifestement il se
préparait on va parler de transfert en
santé parce que c'est demain la fameuse
rencontre on voit monsieur Lego
aujourd'hui très enthousiaste il semble
optimiste les premiers ministres on
écoute le temps de Monsieur LEGO
après deux ans enfin d'avoir un une
rencontre avec Monsieur Trudeau puis
deux d'avoir une proposition nous a dit
qu'il va déposer une proposition
maintenant on va voir le montant on a
demandé que ça soit une proposition sans
condition donc on va savoir ça demain
puis nous les premiers ministres on se
rend compte ce soir là puis on a
toujours un beau front commun
ils sont toujours jusqu'à maintenant un
beau front commun comme le dit Monsieur
Lego alors Hélène là il sera en compte
ensemble les premiers ministres des
provinces et territoires et c'est demain
qu'ils vont rencontrer Monsieur le goût
à votre avis est-ce qu'ils ont raison
d'être optimiste
je retiens je retiens un peu mon souffle
et mon optimisme oui je pense qu'il va y
avoir beaucoup d'argent sur la table
encore que c'est assez particulier qu'il
y a absolument rien qui est filtré de la
proposition fédérale tout au plus c'est
tant que on a en tête une entente sur 10
ans mais c'est pas vraiment étonnant ça
toujours été le genre d'objectif qu'on
se donnait le de se donner une décennie
alors on n'a pas le montant et on a
surtout pas les conditions ou les
paramètres de ce montant et c'est ça qui
sera important moi je note quand même
quelque chose de particulier c'est que
vous l'avez dit les premiers ministres
se rencontrent entre eux d'abord dans un
lieu et la rencontre ensuite avec
Monsieur Trudeau elle se fera sur un à
un autre endroit donc monsieur Trudeau a
vraiment voulu faire ça sur son
territoire et la rencontre prévue entre
lui et ses homologues promotion n'est à
peine que de deux heures de 1h à 3
heures bon je serais vraiment pas étonné
que ça se prolonge mais quand même c'est
très très on sent que Monsieur Trudeau
veut rester maître de l'agenda il va
arriver là il va exposer sa proposition
dire ce qu'il a en tête et là les
premiers ministres pourront à ce
moment-là réagir mais ce sera très bref
donc on veut pas vraiment donner le on
veut pas rejouer dans ce grand théâtre
qu'on a vu dans le passé avec d'autres
premiers ministres libéraux Paul Martin
Jean-Chrétien de ces grandes conférences
qui disaient qui durait 1 2 3 jours il
ne veut pas jouer là-dedans donc il va
exposer ses chiffres et ensuite on va
dire bon allez réfléchir à tout ça et on
se reparlera d'ici notre budget fédéral
on comprend que c'est important pour les
provinces évidemment l'argent santé mais
Émilie en plus c'est important pour
Justin Trudeau de réussir sur ce coup-là
de d'avoir des premiers ministres des
provinces qui sortent sans déchirer
leurs chemises demain
parce que c'est en fait impossible de
faire un budget fédéral et des budgets
provincial si cette question-là est pas
réglée on parle de quantité d'argent sur
sur un plan d'ailleurs qu'on sait
maintenant sur 10 ans donc la
planification fiscale si cette
question-là peut régler devient devient
à peu près impossible c'est aussi bien
sûr un test un test de leadership pour
le Premier ministre et je pense que
c'est impossible pour Justin Trudeau de
pas réussir mais c'est aussi impossible
pour les provinces de ne pas réussir
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a beaucoup de
Canadiens d'un peu partout dans les
différentes provinces qui sont très
inquiets de l'état actuel du système de
santé peut-être que ça m'a été le récit
au moins été ça au Québec mais hier au
Canada l'idée que si les provinces
elles-mêmes refusent de signer une
entente en santé elles vont
essentiellement porter le blanc
politique de la des ratés qui continuent
à se passer dans les urgences cette
pression là est tellement forte qu'en
fait il y a personne
intérêt politiquement ni le Premier
ministre juste intrudo ni les premiers
ministres des provinces à reculer à pas
trouver un terrain d'entente et je pense
que bien sûr l'honneur d'AGA ça va être
la question de l'argent donc le
pourcentage que le fédéral est prêt à
contribuer et pas encore sur la table on
va tout le monde va la prendre demain
donc c'est ça vaut vraiment être sur ce
chiffre-là qui risque d'avoir des
négociations plus que je pense sur le
coeur général que si cette question là
est encore en étape de brouillon on
aurait effectivement prévu une rencontre
de plus plus longue que ça Jonathan
monsieur Legault parle du beau front
commun alors ça c'est le rapport de
force qui sont en train d'installer mais
on est déjà vu des front communs assez
rapidement dans ce genre de négociation
là
le risque dans un front commun c'est que
le fédéral des fois puisse avoir des
attentes particulières avec des
provinces et l'avenir briser le front
commun mais de ce qu'on comprend ça fait
déjà partie de l'Entente en ce moment
c'est-à-dire d'avoir des ententes
spécifiques bilatérales avec chacune
montante
bilatérales sur certains thèmes
exactement donc
je pense qu'à ce statut il est assez
solide le front commun et je pense que
la pression est particulièrement sur sur
Justin Trudeau pourquoi parce que son
gouvernement a contribué à vraiment
augmenter les attentes je trouve au
cours des deux trois dernières semaines
plusieurs articles ici comme ailleurs
dans le Canada anglais qui font état de
ce qu'on a entendu à plusieurs reprises
le disant les entendre bilatérale etc
donc les attentes sont très très élevés
moi je pense que je t'intrudo il a une
obligation de réussite à deux niveaux
premièrement de façon très terre à terre
les Canadiens canadiennes attendent que
il y a entente et qu'on puisse
redistribuer cet argent-là dans le
système de santé donc au politique
l’impression que les Canadiens et les
Canadiens disent entendez-vous mais sont
se concentre sur le le front politique
il a bien besoin de démontrer qu'il est
capable d'en arriver à des entendre
constructives surtout après les
dernières semaines avec les sorties sur
la clause etatoires la nomination
controversée de la semaine dernière ne
serait-ce que pour son leadership à
l'intérieur du caucus et pour le message
qu'il envoie un peu partout au Canada
Justin Trudeau a bien besoin d'une
victoire dans les prochains jours alors
ça expose bien effectivement là où
chacun se situe quel gain et quel risque
qu'il prend actuellement Émilie tantôt
quand vous avez parlé des gens qui
attendent qui ont qui sont desservis par
leur système de santé qui regarde les
tous les paliers de gouvernement disant
vous avez intérêt à vous entendre si
cette impression qu'il y a des choses
qui ne tournent pas rond au pays un
message que Martel de plus en plus
souvent monsieur poignet avec une phrase
comme ceci on va l'écouter
qu'est-ce qui se passe dans notre pays
une grande augmentation dans la
criminalité le coût de la vie
les morts à cause des drogues le chaos
total dans nos aéroports et notre
système de rail
tout semble être brisé
la situation actuelle les choses sont
tellement décourageantes la pénurie de
main-d’œuvre en fait j'ai pas besoin de
faire la nomenclature le pénurie de
logement etc
ce qui est intéressant je pense c'est
que ce sont d'âge là viennent nous
confirmer la stratégie de Pierre Paulien
le chef conservateur que l'on entendait
moi je le dis depuis un certain temps
que vous aurez remarqué que Monsieur
poignet depuis son élection à la tête du
parti à l'automne dernier ne propose à
peu près rien de nouveau il ne se
positionne pas par rapport aux grands
enjeux même qu'on parle par exemple du
financement de la santé ou des choses
comme ça au même tout le débat sur
Madame el ghaouabi il s'est tenu
beaucoup en retrait et ça la stratégie
des conservateurs semble être de dire
les libéraux vont se défaire eux-mêmes à
cause de cette situation morose plus ou
moins généralisée dans la société et
donc clairement monsieur Poirier met le
doigt sur un bobo il sent il sent l'état
d'esprit d'une majorité de Canadiens et
il ne fait que renforcer ce message qui
existe déjà sans se commettre lui par
ailleurs sur autre chose et on le voit
dans les sondages les conservateurs
commencent à prendre les devants sur les
libéraux les corps se grandit se
creusent mais en même temps les libéraux
peuvent dormir tranquille parce que par
ailleurs le NPD ne bouge pas ces
intentions de vote restent toujours plus
ou moins à 18 % et ça c'est un puissant
incitatif pour continuer à appuyer les
libéraux et donc leur permettre de
terminer leur mandat théoriquement
jusqu'en 2025 bon et la question Émilie
puis il resterait peu de temps moins une
minute monsieur poignet sont raccourcis
finalement c'est dire tout votre aimable
le Canada est brisé c'est de la faute à
Justin Trudeau mais est-ce que les
Canadiens font cette lecture là c'est à
dire ils peuvent dire à 67% qui trouve
que ça va mal mais on sait pas jusqu'à
quel point ils disent c'est de la faute
juste un truc tôt faudrait faire un
autre tournage mais ceci dit ce que
c'est dit ce qu'on a vu dans les
derniers échanges depuis le temps des
fêtes en fait c'est que quand Pierre
Poirier 26 sur le problème lorsque ce
que Justin Trudeau lui répond c'est
voici les solutions qu'on met de l'avant
et puis insister sur les problèmes sans
mettre de la vendre des solutions c'est
pas du leadership donc la question c'est
est-ce que ça le message pour de Pierre
Poivre et zone oui est-ce que ça fait de
lui une personne que les gens voient
comme une personne qui sera un bon
premier ministre qui apporte qui
apporterait les solutions ça c'est un
deuxième c'est un deuxième point qui est
encore qui reste encore à tester quand
tu réflexion là-dessus Jonathan
ça démonte une double conjoncture
premièrement économique c'est à dire que
les gens sont étoufflés l'inflation
l'augmentation du coût de la vie
s'apaise également politique
c'est-à-dire la lassitude du
gouvernement Trudeau 8 années au pouvoir
et d'ailleurs puis après équitable
là-dessus à dire c'est un gouvernement
qui est usé c'est maintenant le temps de
le remplacer on verra jusqu'à quel point
ça va porter ce message là je vous
remercie tous les trois d'avoir été avec
nous Emilie Hélène Jonathan bonne soirée
bonne soirée au revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI